this is the story of how we might
discover life outside our solar system
here is a star in our galaxy it's a bit
cooler than our Sun which means it emits
more red light and less blue light it's
also a little smaller which means it
emits less energy this Orage star
therefore has habitable zone that's
closer in than our own Sun by luck a
planet forms in that habitable zone not
too cold not too hot the planet is a
terrestrial world composed of rock and
metal though at this time the entire
blind is molten its large for a
terrestrial world heavier than our earth
what we would call a super earth now
asteroids and comments bombard the super
during its formation sometimes really
violently the surface remains molten for
many many years the planet's
gravitational pull also captures a few
asteroids which becomes small moves a
suppliant cause its outer layer becomes
solid using the first trust for our
super earth beneath the crust is the
thick liquid mantle with convection
currents these start the process of
plate tectonics
the planet crust will be moved and
recycled over time the water and gas is
delivered by all the bombarding comment
contribute to the planet's atmosphere
the planet Simonson's resulting
gravitational pull allows it to retain a
fairly thick atmosphere this will be
essential in protecting its surface from
heavy radiation from its star and will
also help moderate the atmospheric
temperature of the planet cools even
further atmospheric water vapor becomes
liquid and drains down onto the planet
seas and lakes develop because the
planet in its star's habitable zone most
of that water will remain liquid though
the planet may develop ice caps like our
own or the ones on planet Mars we now
have a place of shelter where many
elements mix together in a warm churning
sea this is the sort of environment
where life can develop brains bring
nutrients from the land onto the scene
where they collect along the shoreline
these mixing chemicals with some energy
from heat light and electrical
discharges combine to form amino acids
lipids and other simple organic
molecules these in turn react with each
other to produce longer and more complex
molecules similar to RNA these molecules
both store information and catalyze
their own creation making it easier to
form more of this alien RNA the process
actually helps itself continue
now bubbles from the sea foam collect
lipid forming a simple surface the first
prototypes of cell membranes as time
goes on these bubbles fill with water
salt and nutrients as well as some of
this alien RNA when these surfaces allow
certain molecules to enter and others to
leave we have the first true self the
alien RNA provides genetic information
and replication the nutrient-rich
saltwater provides the cytoplasm the
bubble of lipids provides the cell
membrane so cells require genetic
material see to blossom in a membrane in
this environment has created all three
of them at this point evolution becomes
possible when the RNA replicates itself
enough it will split the bubble into in
cell division begins the alien RNA will
be changed by radiation or education
errors and other factors in each
generation has changed the cells are
challenged by their environment so cells
which changes that don't help them
survive and reproduce will be crowded
out by the cells which changes that do
help them survive and replicate several
processes will become more complex than
through bust in this evolving life will
be able to survive beyond the place
where it first arose as the cells divide
and produce more and more of the planet
becomes a home to life in life even
single-celled life like this reduces
byproducts modern plant life on earth
produces oxygen gas but early life on
earth found oxygen poisonous so we know
that not all life needs or produces
oxygen life on our hypothetical planet
produces methane as a by-product as well
as nitrous oxide
these chemicals will be our clue that
life is present on this superb now back
on earth we're surveying the sky for new
planets at some time in our future our
telescopes happen to view this star the
star brightness and color tell us about
its size and its mass we see the stars
brightness dim periodically indicating
that it may have a planet orbiting
killed with a transit we can detect
continued observations confirms this
cyclic on light pattern so we bring new
instruments to focus on the star
examining this light curve closely and
using what we know about the stars own
size we can estimate the size of the
planet now we bring a spectrometer to
use and it's let's see very precisely
what colors of light coming from the
star discovers oscillate as the star
moves towards us and away from us due to
the Doppler shift effect knowing how
fast the star moves and how massive it
is we determine the mass of the planet
as well as the radius of the planet's
orbit from all these information we on
earth find out that the planet is within
its star's habitable zone in that it is
a super earth now we examine it more
closely
[Music]
very careful work with the spectrometer
will tell us what colors of light coming
from the planet int which wavelengths
that block by its atmosphere most
interesting to us a spectral lines that
would indicate the presence of volatile
gases like oxygen gas nitrous oxide or
methane in the planet's atmosphere the
spectral lines from this planet showed
great amount of methane gas much more
than could be explained by volcanoes or
other non life based sources as we
watched carefully over the course of
several years we confirm the presence of
methane as well as nitrous oxide another
marker of biological life the evidence
is clear we have found the planet with
life well this is only one way the story
might come out for now we will need to
keep watching keep exploring as new
technologies and techniques improve our
ability to view and measure the universe
it's only a matter of time